there are bad bosses out there but
what's not talked about as much as
there's also good bosses and so what we
sought out to do is find out whether you
could met and measure the productivity
of individual employees and see if
productivity really rose for individual
employees if they happen to be working
with a good boss and so what we did is
gather data on workers productivity and
find wow there's a big effect from a
good boss relative to a bad boss what we
got access to was data on what we call
technology based service workers who
have their performance timed and that
enables us to measure their productivity
so that's the foundation of the study is
productivity and then given their
productivity which would be really how
many customers they treat an hour would
be an example of productivity you can
then see if people with good bosses
treat more customers per hour than
people with bad bosses and what we find
is that there's an enormous range of
productivity based on who your boss is
and that is if you're working on your
job and you change to someone who has a
history of being a good boss your
productivity definitely goes up the
original data set we use Todd data on
productivity and so that's how we
identified whether bosses matter is
linking it to productivity a data set
like this doesn't really have the traits
of the boss so in order to look at the
traits of what makes a good boss we
needed to do a case study and so we did
a case study on the Royal Bank of Canada
so they have a enormous workforce it's
the biggest bank in Canada and they have
a lot of data and so we look to them to
see what the traits of a good boss
appear to be and there's a sequence in
order to identify the traits of a big
boss of a good boss so to identify the
traits of a good boss first you have to
tell again whether boss is matter
and so what we show is that workers are
more engaged in their work in their
workplace and are more productive when
they have a good boss in this case and
so you really see that in what's called
engagement data which is data that asks
you know do you feel motivate on your
job you know do you feel do you identify
with your company and sure enough those
people who are motivated and identify
with their company are higher performers
and then given that they're high
performers we look to see well what do
their boss is doing differently the
first thing they do is they set the
vision so what's the vision for this
company and how do you fit personally
fit into that vision that's what they do
for their subordinates the next thing
they do is they drive results so they
make sure the teams and the individuals
are productive and feeling that they are
contributing and so this they would do
by a lot of teaching training of their
subordinates a lot of motivating those
sorts of things the next thing they do
is they really manage day-to-day
workflow to make sure that the workflow
that you're getting is commensurate with
what it is you're doing the last thing
is they measure crew and they manage
career goals so it turns out that what
is incredibly motivating to an
individual is for them to have a vision
for where their career is going to go
and so a good boss will share that
vision with them will give them guidance
and where they're going and give them
good feedback to help them along the
path so most workers are not stagnant
but they have other aspirations they
want to move on or they just want to do
their day to day job well and have that
fit into their career and a good boss
will help them do that
what Google did is a couple years ago
they started a project called project
oxygen and what Google was finding was
that people didn't like their bosses
they didn't think they were useful and
there was even a sense that they should
have no bosses within Google but they
found out as they cut back in the number
of bosses people just went to leaders
for routine tasks and it was a burden on
leaders they found they really needed
low-level managers but they needed to
find out well what makes a good manager
and Google is interesting because they
have so much data so they have data on
workers performance they have data on
the traits of bosses because they do
these evaluations constantly there are
data intense company and then they look
to identify people who manage them and
what their traits are and the traits are
really aligned with the traits I
discussed at Google I mean at RBC and
that their traits that are you pay
attention to your employees you give
them a vision you motivate them and you
set out career goals for them so even
though we think of Google as being
engineers who are kind of self-directed
and want to work alone and not be
subject to the supervision of a boss
when a boss can help them with their
career goals they're quite happy to work
with a good boss
after you leave a good boss does the
effect of that good boss linger on your
performance so you can imagine that if
you have a good boss and they train you
how to do your job well that you're
going to be productive even as you get
switched to lower-level boss and we did
find that that happens that people's
productivity lingers and therefore our
conclusion is that in that study we
could see that one trait of a boss seems
to be teaching because you've learned
something that you carry with you with
the rest of your you know career and so
that teaching could be how to do your
job or it could be something like you
know how to be motivated of surrounding
your career goals but in some way or
another a good boss is teaching
something that lingers and so that's
what we were able to show in that study